hello everyone and welcome to the final
two days of the super United rapid and
Blitz tournament currently being played
in Zagreb Croatia after the three days
of Rapid now we have two days of Blitz
and the first game that finished uh from
the first round of the Blitzer is
Fabiano Corona versus Magnus Carlson
it's a game that really shows uh that it
doesn't matter if the position is
objectively a draw with little time on
the clock and this is five plus two
Blitz which is very little time on the
clock uh it's just not easy to hold the
position that you would normally hold in
Rapid or classical so that being said
let's check out the game for those of
you who haven't seen my previous video
or who are not following what's
happening these are the standings after
three days of Rapid so uh Fabian Nepal
are leading determined with 12 points
Magnus in third place with 11 and then
we have uh Anand and Lucas antenna and
araporta 9 even charged with six and
lupus with two so now uh in the previous
three days they got two points for a win
in Rapid but now they will only get one
point for a winning blitz so you have to
grind out a lot more wins in order to
get that many points but they play more
games they had only nine games of Rapid
they will have 18 games of Blitz so and
now that we've said that let's check it
out Fabi has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to D4 and Magnus had a
nice tip of his water and a replied with
Pawn to D5 we have Pawn to C4 E6 Knight
to F3 and the D captors and C4 going for
the Rosenthal variation accepting the
Queen's Gambit and as this is Blitz like
I said we are not going to over analyze
the games we are merely going to enjoy
them E4 we have found the B5 and now
Pawn to a for very standard C6 is the
most played move here Magnus plays
Bishop to B7 also something that might
become more popular due to this game
eight characters on B5 and now there is
a game where Bishop captures and C4 was
played it was played by none other than
vishwanathan Anand in 1997 he played it
against Robert hibna if you guys
remember during our Bobby Fischer Saga
while we were covering the 1961
candidates matches that of course fish
are dominated in in the first round uh
Robert himnah faced tigram Petrosian and
he played a brilliant match he drew six
games in a row only for Petros and to
defeat him in the seventh game and thus
losing the match but yeah uh he uh
played this against Donald and I believe
the the game was a draw or rather
unplayed Bishop captures on C4 against
him but you know for those of you who
have followed Bobby Fisher Saga I'm sure
it's a very glad to know who that is
okay Bishop captures on e4 uh yeah so
now there's Captain C4 was played but
here at Knight the C3 and it is now as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game
uh we have Bishop back to B7 as the
bishop is under attack uh we have Bishop
captures and C for grabbing the pawn and
Knight to F6 we have castles and Bishop
to E7 we have Rook D1 and now castles
with Bishop to G5 and pawn to H6 with
Bishop to H4 getting away from the pawn
Knight beat the D7 and not Knight to E5
so a fairly standard Queen's Gambit
accepted ideas Knight captures B
captures and now Knights the D7 avoiding
the queen trade and offering a trade of
Bishop switch a Fabi declines Bishop to
G3 but now Knight to B6 puts pressure on
the bishop here Bishop to D3 and the
bishop to H4 now Magnus uh Fabi develops
the queen prepares to bring the Rook
into the game and Magnus trades Bishops
captures captures and queen to E7 gets
the Queen off of the D file uh Knight to
E4 and now we have Rook after d8 and
okay this is a pretty dangerous setup
you know that Fabi at some point might
even go for some like Knight to F6 check
if the um even if the queen remains on
uh this E7 Square because if the if the
queen comes stage five you're gonna able
to be able to sacrifice capture here put
pressure on this diagonal could be very
nasty so Rook a to B1 first you need to
have your Bishop defended but now King
to f8 Magnus avoids any future trouble
so Knight to F6 if it comes it will not
come with check uh Queen to C2 and now
Rook to D5 a nice Rook leave preparing
to double up here also putting pressure
on the E5 Pawn so Knight to C3 attacking
and the defending and now Rook to D4 we
have Bishop back to F1 offering a rook
trade and the Magnus obliges captures
captures and queen to C5 now
uh you you might also uh think about
what about Rook 38 well here allowing
Queen to H7 would be a bit too much as
it comes with a threat of Checkmate so
that's why Magnus played Queen to C5 and
now he allows Queen to H7 it's not a
problem if you play this Magnus we'll
just grab the pawn and you don't care
the King has these seven square uh the
G7 Pawn is defended black is uh well
even better here so instead after Queen
C5 Queen the E2 was played and now Pawn
to A5 uh advancing the pawn now you
either have already upon an A5 or you
just trade pawns so B captures Bishop
captures attacking the queen and Bishop
here Queen moves to E4 and now Bishop
captures an F1 we have Rook captures and
only now Rook the d8 preparing to lifted
The Rook all the way to D2 We have Rook
to C1 and now Rook to D2 putting
pressure on this F2 Pawn so it has to be
defended Queen back to E1 which is a
shame as fabi's Queen was incredibly
active on uh uh on e4 and while you
might consider something like Queen the
F4 this does uh keep the queen sort of
in the game but it's it's a weird Square
I mean it's not really uh doing all that
much so better Queen T1 and now Magnus
centralizes his Queen with Queen Teddy
for now you have certain problems with
white here if the Rook moves from the
back rank or or the Knight or both of
them then you obviously have to worry
about your back rank issues the F2 Pawn
will be hanging for uh quite a while so
you need to find a way to trade it down
into some sort of an end game so here
are Knights the B5 attacks magnus's
queen queen captures on B2 and The Rook
captures on C7 now 5 is trying to trick
Magnus if Magnus picks up the Knight
then just Queen captures on D2
obviously you can't do that so King to
G8 and now we have Knight to D6 we have
Rook the E2 chasing away the queen queen
to F1 you have to defend that F2 pawn
and now Queen captures on E5 and now
Magnus is up upon but still it's a Blitz
game uh both of them uh very low on time
can you push this for anything more than
a draw uh we have Rook the C1 of course
stopping Rook D1 and now Rook to D2 We
have knighted the C4 now uh offering
more trades and the Magnus has to accept
this knight uh captures with Rook
captures sorry not row captures Queen
was the one that captured uh and now
Pawn to G6 creating some more breeding
room for the king and you want your king
safe if you are to trade down even
further so uh if the Rooks come off the
board of course Magnus would probably
not allow the Queens to come off the
board but Rooks uh definitely so Queen
to C8 with check with King the G7 and
now Queen to C4 Fabi has nothing to do
but wait and see what Magnus will do H5
and now Queen to C6 again just waiting
uh Queen to D4 putting pressure on the
F2 pawn and queen to F3 defending with
Rook to death uh sorry Rook to D3
attacking the queen queen to F4 and now
Rook to D1 with check Magnus now forces
a queen and pawn end game Rook captures
Queen captures and now King to H2 Magnus
again centralizes with Queen to D5 and
queen to E3 now fabi's saying all right
it's move 45 we both have like 10
seconds on the clock uh but we are
getting a two seconds increment uh I
will I will defend and you will of
course try to beat me let's do this so
Magnus starts with Ponte E5 uh Queen to
C3 not allowing the pawn to move any
further now Queen D4 Magnus knows that
if Favi trades down for example of
course the king and pawn end game is
more than winning uh it's a silly thing
to say because winning is like the
ultimate thing but um you know you know
what I meant so Queen to F3 uh Ponte H4
Magnus creating further weaknesses so
you can connect some checks with the
white with the white king and then it
would be much easier for you to actually
trade Queen so G captures on H4 Queen
captures with check and King to G1
uh Queen to F4 offering a queen trade
and even though you will double uh the
pawns if you trade it's still going to
be winning for black so Queen back to E2
Ponte E4 and now Pawn to G3 we have
Queen F3 and now Queen to B2 with check
even if you trade here it's still
winning for black because even though
the white thing is very close to the
pawn you have to go all the way around
to actually capture it so the black king
will defend it and then just uh win the
game so Queen to beat you with check
with King to H7 and now Queen to D4
centralizing and just defending that's
something that you always need to keep
in mind when you are playing uh Blitz
when you have little time on the clock
if you're playing one plus one bullet or
five plus one blades or five plus two
blades uh if you're in a position where
you're defending or attacking centralize
your your queen it's it's gonna bring so
much without you even having to look for
things to do just centralize the queen
and good things will happen so upon to
F6 now Queen nicely defends the pawn and
you will try to bring your king all the
way to H3 and Checkmate the white king
but if of course you know that that's
not going to work out uh like that but
it will help you push those spawns so
King to H2 we have King to H6 now comes
Queen to D2 with check
uh King to H5 and queen to D5 with check
now F5 uh we have Queen to D4 and now
King to G4 we have Queen to C5 uh sorry
Queen to C5 uh and now uh Pawn to E3
here it doesn't seem like you have a way
of continuing the game but Magnus finds
it Ponto E3 still not nothing I mean
it's uh it's a draw but only if you play
Perfect moves Queen to D4 with check
Queen to E4 and now just F characters on
E3 so you have to trade now but Queen a
king to F3 first uh now of course you
cannot trade if you trade now it's gonna
be completely winning you have captors
or King captures whatever is winning so
you have to continue checking so Magnus
gave up a pawn in order to continue his
Onslaught so King to F2 uh Queen to D2
with check king of three and queen to D1
with check Fabi now it has to repeat but
that also means that Magnus will grab
the E3 Pawn we have Queen to E1 with
check King to F3 again Fabi can never
trade um uh Queens here Queen to F1
check King to G4 now Queen to D1 with
checking to G5 Queen to D2 with check
King H5 Queen to D1 check King H6 and
queen to D2 with check and G5 or again
upon move and now Queen to d8 Hero Queen
to D6 check was the way to go but you
know who will see see such things in
Blitz uh and here we have Queen to E2
with Chuck Queen to C2 was a little bit
better as it guards the F5 Pawn but
again it's blitz so King G1 King the H5
and now Queen to D4 stopping the king
from further advancing Queen to E4 and
again Fabi declines we have Queen to G4
and queen to D3 guarding the pawn here
Queen to E4 offering a queen trade and
queen to D1 check King G6 and queen to
D6 jerk so is there a way for Magnus to
actually push this King to F7 Queen D7
check King F6 and now Queen to DH check
Queen to E7 blocking Queen to D for
checking to G6 and now Queen to D3 not
allowing the pawn to move so Queen E1
check now
uh King H2 Queen to F2 checking H1 Queen
to E1 with checking to H2 Queen to B4 uh
now guarding some crucial squares here
uh like the D6 squares you don't allow a
check and now Queen to d8 uh Magnus
plays Queen to B to check King to G1
King to H5 and now Queen back to D1 with
check King to G6 and queen to d8 again
Magnus no way of continuing so Queen to
F6 this is what I meant that he can just
continue this game for as long as he
wants he has increment and he will try
uh he will try uh a thousand ways uh to
hurt Fabi before he actually uh gives
him a draw yeah Queen T8 with check King
to H6 now comes Queen to D7 Queen A1
checking to G2 Queen to B2 checking G1
Queen to E5 King G2 Queen to E4 with
track King F2 and now Queen the C2 check
and this is the funny thing about Chess
King F1 it's a draw King the E3 uh it's
uh it's a draw King to F3 it's a draw
but King to G1 is not an that's just how
chess works and Magnus finds it King the
H5 is the only move that wins uh because
look at this now Queen to D4 same same
idea of Defense but now Queen to E2 uh
Queen to A4 and now Queen to E1 with
check now you have to defend the pawn
here King H2 Queen to have to check King
H1 and queen captures on G3 just grabs
the pawn and now the problem is this
should not be possible
uh but because the fabi's queen is in
such a weird Square you don't have a way
of sacrificing your queen if you could
sacrifice your queen magnus's uh Queen
has fabi's King in the corner it would
be stalemate like if you could play
something like uh Queen captures or or
queen to H6 would check you would
probably be able to to get a draw and
even if you play something like Queen to
E8 would check it's a very fine
variation King to G4 now Queen to E4
with check of course if you capture it's
a draw uh Queen to F4 now Queen to G2
check King to H4 and if Queen to F to
check again the black queen cannot
capture it would be a draw uh Queen to
G3 blocks Queen to D4 check again Queen
to G4 and now Queen to have to check
King to H5 Queen to H2 check or the only
way to continue checking now Queen to H4
and you force a queen trade so now you
would uh actually win so that's why
although it looks very nice it doesn't
really work uh Fabi tried Queen to D1
with check but of course Magnus is not
about to fall for a trick if he goes
back then it is is a draw because you
allow Queen to H5 and such nasty moves
that will allow you to try and sacrifice
the queen forever you know to Infinity
so Queen to G4 uh you know it's uh well
one of the two moves that wins but not a
difficult one to spot for Magnus Queen
to d8 now Queen to E4 with check of
course the checks are now over for Fabi
King to G1 and now you can give one more
Queen to the queen to E1 check uh King
to G2 Queen T to checking to G1 and it
was uh in this position and move
103 uh that the game continued for uh
one more move uh King to G4 was played
Queen to D for check a Ponte F4 and he
was in this position and move 104 uh
that uh Fabiana corvana resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here point is that you have one more
check Queen to D7 check then comes King
G3 and you are getting checkmated
regardless of what you do or if you try
something like Queen F2 of course Magnus
happily tracing because he's up two
points and two points will always be
winning uh unless it's like a doubled
age Pawn uh they they will be winning uh
so yeah uh that's that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
Magnus who catches up to Fabi these were
the standings before the game and we
said that in Blitz you gain one one
point and now depending on how the other
games uh will be played uh you know uh
it's gonna go one way or another uh and
as Magnus said it will it will uh an 8.5
it will have to have a tournament of
their life to stop him as he's feeling
very good about the the blitz section so
he takes a win against Fabi with black
he will meet him again with white we'll
see what happens and if you have any of
your own favorites do use hashtag
suggestion I will try to cover as many
games as possible so once again really
hope you enjoyed it uh I would like to
thank James Eugene Cashman John Austin
not complaced Paul Miller and Brad Roth
for her contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check through my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day